après plus d'un mois de négociations le
jeune attaquant du psg nicolas anelka
dix sept ans et transféré de plaisir
soir au club anglais d'arsenal mettant
fin à un conflit entre les deux clubs au
plan juridique autour des contrats des
stagiaires une solution amiable qui
satisfait les deux parties en attendant
les nouveaux règlements de l'uefa
si cette affaire nous avait permis de
défendre les centres de formation qui
t'a quelle que soit l'issue de la
décision de la fifa où serions allés au
bout aujourd'hui ce dossier et étant en
cours de règlement par la ligue et par
par l'uefa ce qui veut dire qu'une
affaire anelka que n'aura pas d'autres
ce transfert aura rapporté à tout le
monde
preuve qu'il faut d'urgence retravailler
sur ces textes aussi bien les textes de
la charte ici en france qu'au niveau de
l'ue f1 pour protéger la formation en
duplex au téléphone depuis londres
arsène wenger l'entraîneur d'arsenal
compte sur sa nouvelle recrue